yesterday
in my view one of the darkest days in
the history of our nation
an unprecedented assault on our
democracy
an assault literally on the citadel of
liberty
in the united states capital itself an
assault on the rule of law
an assault on the most sacred of
american
ratifying the will of the people
and choosing the leadership of their
government
all of us here grieve the loss of life
grieve the desecration of the people's
house
but we what we witnessed yesterday was
not dissent
it was not disorder it was not protest
it was chaos they weren't protesters
don't dare call them protesters they
were
a riotous mob insurrectionist
domestic terrorist it's that basic it's
that
simple and i wish we
could say we couldn't see it coming
we could see it coming the past
four years we've had a president who's
made his contempt for our democracy
our constitution the rule of law
clear in everything he has done
he unleashed an all-out assault
on our institutions of our democracy
from the outset and yesterday was what
the culmination of that
unrelenting attack who dared to question
his power
repeatedly calling the free press the
enemy
of the people language at the time he
first used it i
and others said has long been used by
autocrats and dictators
all over the world to hold on to power
the enemy of the people language
that is being used now by autocrats and
dictators across the world
only this time with the imperative of an
outgoing president of the united states
of america
he's attacked our intelligence services
who dared tell the american people the
truth
about the effort of a foreign power to
elect him four years ago
choosing instead to believe the word of
vladimir putin
over the word of those who've sworn
their allegiance
to this nation many of whom
had risked their lives in the service of
this nation
he deployed the united states military
tear-gassing peaceful protesters in
pursuit of a photo opportunity
in the service of his reelection even
holding the bible
upside down the action
that led to an apology from the chairman
of the joint chiefs of staff
and an outspoken denunciation
of the use of military for domestic
political purposes
from scores scores of former military
leaders
and secretaries of defense led by
secretary cheney
he thought he could stack the courts
with friendly judges
who would support him no matter what
they were
trump judges he needed nine justices on
the supreme court because
because he thought the election would
end up in the supreme court
and they would hand him the election
he was stunned truly stunned
when the judges he appointed didn't do
his bidding instead acted with integrity
following the constitution upholding the
rule of law
not just once or twice or three times
but over
60 times let me say over 60 times
in more than 60 cases in state after
state after state
and then at the supreme court judges
including people considered
quote his judges trump judges
use his words looked at the
allegations that trump was making and
determined they were without
any merit
nothing was judged to
put this election in question or doubt
by any of these
judges you want to understand the
importance of democratic institutions in
this country
take a look at the judiciary in this
nation
take a look at the pressure it was just
subjected to
by a sitting president of the united
states of america
at every level the judiciary rose at the
moment during this election
did its job acted with complete
fairness and impartiality with complete
honor and
integrity when history looks back in
this moment as just
we've just passed through i believe it
will say our democracy survived in no
small part
because of the men and women who
represent an independent judiciary in
this nation
we owe them a deep deep debt of
gratitude
and then there's the attack on the
department of justice
treating the attorney general as his
personal lawyer in the department as his
personal law firm
through it all we would hear the same
thing from the president my generals
my judges my attorney general
and then yesterday a culmination of
attack on our institutions of democracy
this time the congress itself
inciting a mob to attack the capital to
threaten elected representatives
of the people of this nation and even
the vice president
to stop the congress from ratifying the
will of the american people
in a just completed free and fair
election trying to use a mob
to silence the voices of nearly 160
million
americans who summoned the courage
in the face of a pandemic that
threatened their health
and their lives to cast that
sacred ballot
i made it clear from the moment i
entered this race
that what i believe was at stake
i said there was nothing less at stake
than who we are as a nation
what we stand for what we believe
what we will be at the center of that
belief
is one of the oldest principles this
nation has long held
we are a government of laws not of men
not of the people
of laws i said it many times in the
campaign
our democrat our democratic institutions
are not relics of another age
they're what sets this nation apart
they're the guard rails of our democracy
and there's no president there's that's
why there is
no president who is a king
no congress that's a house of lords
a judiciary just to protect him or her
we have three co-equal branches of
government
co-equal our president is not above the
law
justice serves the people
it doesn't protect the powerful
justice is blind what we saw
yesterday in plain view was another
violation of the fundamental tenet of
this nation
not only did we see the failure to
protect one of the three branches of our
government
we also saw a clear failure to carry out
equal justice
i don't know if he used to say in the
senate excuse a point of personal
privilege
a little over an hour and a half after
the chaos started i got a
text from my granddaughter finnegan
biden who's a senior
in her last semester at the university
of pennsylvania
she sent me a photo
of military people in full
military gear scores of them
lining the steps of the lincoln memorial
because of protests by black lives
matter
she said pop this isn't fair
no one can tell me that it had been a
group of black lives matter protesting
yesterday
there wouldn't have been they wouldn't
have been treated very very differently
than the mob of thugs that stormed the
capitol
well we all know that's true and it is
unacceptable
totally unacceptable the american people
saw it in plain view
and i hope it's sensitized into what we
have to do
not many people know it when justice
carl and i were talking
we talked about i think he raised it the
reason
for the justice department was formed in
the first place
was back in 1870 we didn't have a
justice department before that
the cabinet it was formed in 1870
to enforce the civil rights amendment
that grew out of the civil war
the 13th 14th and 15th amendments
to stand up to the klan to stand up to
racism to take on domestic terrorism
this original spirit must again
guide and animate its work
so as we stand here today we do so in
the wake of yesterday's events
events that could not more have vividly
demonstrated
some of the most important work we have
to do in this nation